but this brings me to our next story one
of the most shocking and devastating
follow-ups to the january 6 moment uh
january 6 riots
now this one is uh as many of you know
an insurrection an insurrection took
place at the capitol
people were trying to uh insurrect
against this government in support of
donald trump but since then we've had
another moment that was also as bad
cnn reports
joe rogan's use of the n-word is another
january 6 moment that's right joe rogan
over ten years doing a show in which he
said a word in in in context of
referencing other people and comedy
specials
is as bad
as the storming of the
capitals as the resident n-word i will
say
that um
neither are are that bad
it's correct
not i gotta say neither are that bad but
i have to say that
on the scale of things the the the rogan
n-word thing is like way down here
i'll tell you what this is just very
simply put
someone at cnn was like
hey look we looked at the metrics joe
rogan's getting a lot of hits and so is
january 6. can we put those together
and so they did and it makes literally
no sense it would be like if someone
said uh whoopi goldberg's comments on
the view are
the next bernie madoff moment and then
just writing while she didn't try and
steal money from powerful individuals
the things she said shows how power in
this country and you're like wait wait
hold on a minute
you're just taking two things and saying
them at the same time in no way are they
in any way related anyway comparable
yeah but you're hoping it gets traffic
oh i just found out that they changed
the title they did change their title
okay so
what's the new title the note the new
title i believe this is it why shrugging
off joe rogan's use of the n-word is so
dangerous it's not even a sentence it's
a sentence fragment so they posted the
original story they got massive amounts
of heat about what an idiotic statement
yeah and then within 24 hours january
from the article or that part is still
in there it's still in the same article
is it the same guy the same analysis by
john yeah yeah so so it's it's the same
article if you take the original it's
got a different photo yeah and it says
january 6 moment they say what rogan and
those that defend him have done since
video clips of him using the n-word
surface on social media is arguably just
as dangerous as what a mob did when they
stormed the u.s capitol on january 6
last year
the same paragraph is right here yo i'm
sorry
this is one of the most psychotic things
this is the ramblings of an incoherent
madman behind a 7-eleven at 2 a.m and
he's sputtering and spitting on himself
it's the kind of thing you hear when
you're at a bar until 3 a.m and you're
in new york city and you walk outside
and there's some crazy guy walking down
the street and in a dirty green coat
with like a striped muddy ripped shirt
and a crazy beard and white poofy hair
and he's going hard get your toe broken
like january 6. and you're like whoa
calm down there old man this is getting
a little loud out of control
it feels like
a very vivid picture you just painted
i'm not gonna lie
when they use this language like stopped
him from using the n-word and using the
n-word
it makes me feel like this guy's playing
with gi joe's and it's the drama is in
the little
joe action that he's doing like that's
the drama it's not real life
that's exactly what it's like but then i
gotta accept that it's on cnn and people
are reading this and thinking it's real
or normal
i could come on if this isn't if if this
doesn't wake somebody up
i i don't i think they're beyond help
they kind of like
like just just subtly change that title
as there's no right but but look look
you can take this here here's my tip to
all of you at home
google search the story why shrugging
off joe rogan's use of the n-word is so
dangerous copy the url up top
go to archive dot is
yes and you can then paste that in
and look at the first version of the
article which shows you the original
archived you can also take a look at we
have here at the top of the screen
archive dot fo slash capital t lowercase
e capital z lowercase y capital x
that is the direct link to this story
and just show your nay say your friends
show your parents and your family
members who don't believe you when you
say the media is lying to them and just
ask them to reconcile this and explain
to you what it means
and if they still still believe and
trust cnn and defend them anyway you can
just hug them and say
you know i'm so yeah i'm so sorry so the
third paragraph is actually throwing me
for the biggest loop
saying
the the concept of white people not
saying the n-word has held america
together since world war ii
um
i hate to break it to you guys people
still say it they're always gonna say it
there's no law against saying it and it
world war ii seems so arbitrary like jim
crow still existed during world war ii
like what are they even saying what are
they talking about why'd they pick that
it's called america together it's like
if you were in finland and they were
like well you know what keeps america
together well when you ask when i think
about it what keeps america together is
that white people don't say they were
storming
search on this article and the phrase
n-word appears 30 times in this article
talk about propaganda what what
is this it's it's look look they they i
kid you not
somebody just said i want to get the
algorithm boost
i'm not kidding i i would be willing to
bet a large amount of money that this
guy who wrote this john blake was
sitting in his room and he's like
bouncing his pen and he's like i want to
get a million million hits what can i do
what can i do he's like
google search
he goes to google trends he looks the
top 10 phrases and he sees joe rogan
january 6th and he goes yeah all right
let's write that one down and that's
what he did i thought i'd be wearing a
bed that's what he did i saw the
screenshot of this headline earlier
without the link so i didn't know it was
from cnn i literally assumed it was
either the onion or babylon b yeah i
laughed at it i thought it was satire
this is me live finding out that it's on
scene what is up with white and black
being capitalized all of a sudden so
black is now normally capitalized but
now look at white island capitalized
by this guy it is at first i think it
was only black that was capitalized
because the references to the politics
and ideology so they're not even talking
about color anymore no shade but here's
here's what i want to point out too
because we did mention this a little bit
it says publicly use
all right let's play a game
we're into a spelling bee real quick oh
god all right uh don't ask me to say
anything i don't want to say it ask me
to spell a word
i can choose the word no no uh yes yes
uh tim spell the word banana banana uh
can you use banana in a sentence
uh
i would like to eat a banana all right
you are it's a noun you are referencing
that in the sentence now i'm gonna ask
you to spell the word and i want you to
ask me to use the the word and
definition all right okay all right your
word is
oikoinomia
oikonomia could you use it in a sentence
please tim poole said the word oyconomia
that in no way used the word it
referenced the word in uh uh i'll say
this let's let's try again uh your word
is
there
there
could you use it in a sentence tim poole
said the word there
now spell it
yes uh t-h-e-y apostrophe-r
the reason you use it
the reason why using a word
is different from saying a word is that
when you're trying to spell it and
figure out what the word is
making a sentence where it's like tim
poole said the word there does not tell
you which there it is yeah so joe rogan
never used the word
to use it in in a context of which is to
insult or deride someone he said the
word in reference to other people
they they purposefully do this
to prey on weak minds and the ignorant
to smear their political opponents to
make money to generate outrage and in no
way is it true it was never true and i i
gotta say
i
i think joe needs to sue cnn hmm yes i
really really do because when they said
joe does sandman take a page out of his
book well hold on this is a factual
question and i think it needs to be
expressed so long as everyone keeps
accepting that saying a word equals
using it
go to go before a judge
and then ask the judge and i want the
judge to answer okay
it's that simple
so joe could file the suit
he doesn't have to do this i get it but
i wish someone would and he can say to
the judge
your answer here will set a standard a
cultural precedent
is saying a word the same as using the
word and if the judge says we think
cnn's description of what you did is
correct thank you you've you've now
defined it and everyone knows the courts
believe that saying a word means using
the word
but i'd be willing to bet based on my
spelling bee argument the judge would
probably be like yeah there's a
difference between saying a word and
using it yeah
until someone sues for defamation you
know gets that clarification now i do
love we had this conversation before
about the you know joe rogan and other
issues like this and the left then
claims tim poole you know does a show
where he demands the right to use the
n-word and things like that that's the
game
yeah yeah no i think nobody should use
the n-word no well one of the things
also going back to what we were talking
about earlier on the podcast is uh and
the media as a whole and how i think
they're responsible for a lot of the
frustration and animosity and anger
that's brewing in the country
and you were saying how they'll never be
held accountable for what they what they
have put out or they'll never make
mistake you know apologize
changing the headline is is a precedent
that has only come about because of the
internet because before if they wrote it
in time magazine like the famous time
magazine madam president with hillary
clinton that they publish too quickly
right it lives in perpetuity but the new
york times has been found often going
back to articles five months old five
years old and subtly making changes now
if you have the print version you know
it or this website that has the archived
version
but but they don't have to stand by
their reporting because even in real
time if the tide turns against it they
can just change the headline and that's
and that's not reporting now now you're
doing opinion journalism if you really
believe his use of the n word was like
january 6 then make that headline and
damn it stand by it yeah and argue your
case but to say like oh that was stupid
let me rephrase the practice of changing
the headline is more dangerous than joe
rogers saying the n-word absolutely
dangerous absolutely well said so um
here's my pitch
the cnn article
where they accused joe rogan of using
the n-word and comparing it to january 6
is another january 6 month
oh yeah i like that take yeah that's
tight it's it's it's now they may not
have died
doing it but
but
it is very dangerous to our democrats
the young turks tomorrow tim poole's
podcast saying that joe rogan's use of
the n-word was not a january sixth
moment is a january six months
and it's gonna go on and on
let me play again with you guys
i'm going to read you this uh article
from cnn
jankuger's use of the n word is another
january 6 moment
the tv show host jenk yuger did not join
a mob that forced lawmakers to flee for
their lives he never carried a
confederate flag inside the u.s capitol
rotunda no one died trying to stop him
from using the n-word
but what anna kasparian another host in
the show and those that defend her have
done since video clips of her using the
n-word surface on social media is
arguably just as dangerous as what a mob
did when they stormed the us capital
hassan [ __ ] breached a civic norm that
has been held together held america
together since world war ii it's an
unspoken agreement that we would never
return to the kind of country we used to
be that agreement revolved around the
simple rule a white person would never
be able to publicly use the n-word again
and not pay a price
hassan has said it
and anna kasparian and genkuger have
both said it in the exact same context
as joe the use of the word this word
descriptively referencing someone's body
of work
statements made by another person
and the funny thing is when people
brought up the young turks
anna said oh it was all taken out of
context and i'm like anna's right and it
should not be held against her i think
the young kirk young turk should not be
criticized for criticizing other people
papa john was criticizing colonel
sanders and they destroyed his life over
this it's selective the point is cnn
writes the article about about joe rogan
even though in the exact same context
they could have written about the young
turks people are defending them oh but
they're on the they're on the top
they're in the right side of the
political hierarchy so the media is on
their side yeah and that's the other
form of media bias which is is
more prevalent and more pernicious is
the medio bias bio mission so they just
won't write that piece on the young
turks just like today the the
the today show will just not talk about
the durham case they'll just ignore it
pretend it didn't happen and they'll
talk us about something else they didn't
write anything about any of this with
joe until robert malone was on the show
basically peter mccull and robert malone
right i mean the reason why people
didn't freak out about these episodes
where he used the n-word at the time is
because people watched the full episode
and they got the context
this midas touch of patriot takes
compilation is making people freak out
who don't watch the show who have never
seen the show who don't understand the
context that he was using it in and it's
insane to your point they omit and
ignore multiple several members of the
media that have done way worse than this
i mean it's jimmy kimmel jimmy fallon
howard stern they've all done blackface
like literal blatant blackface and i'm
not saying i'm sitting here calling for
them to be canceled or for them to write
me a personal apology i'm just saying
they're ignoring people based on which
side of the aisle they're on hmm justin
trudeau wore a black face on more times
than he can remember yeah what was that
brown face everything he said he
couldn't remember he doesn't know how
many times he's done it it looked like
he was in a play
he was performing in brown face i'm
pretty sure yeah like that turban on or
something and northam uh ralph northam
yeah yeah well he didn't even i don't
think he admitted if he was the the clan
member he was a black face
i think the black face is a little bit
better i think he implied that that was
him but it was never invented
we're not sure
were you the guy in the hood or the guy
that's like i'm the governor i shouldn't
be yeah
good lord
that that was funny it was like a clan
member or were you just buddies with the
clan member well no but it's like that
question like when did you stop beating
your wife yes the implication is you did
yeah so it's like you got a photo of
ralph northam he's either the guy in
blackface or the clan hood and neither
is going to be good for him he could do
that get real like when did you stop
beating your wife and he's like i didn't
you didn't stop then they take it as you
didn't
that is actually good i i did what are
you talking about wow and then you know
the governor did not stop beating wife
that's how the media plays it they know
they do it let me tell you a story
there's this guy who who would write for
the boston globe
and uh this was back in uh i think it's
like 2018.
do you guys remember the based stick man
yeah yes so at the battle you know about
this basic man nope no so the battle of
berkeley this is when they were doing
the free speech rallies at the berkeley
park in california and antifa showed up
and was fighting you know they beat up a
bunch of trump supporters so the trump
supporters came back and this guy showed
up wearing a helmet goggles and he had i
think he had a shield right like a
shield and a stick yeah and then when
antifa attacked he cracked the stick
over an antifa person's head shattering
it and the video went viral and everyone
called him the based stickman
and uh
this writer this journalist i've known
for a long time called him a white
nationalist
and so i was like well that's weird he
was in a mixed threat he was in a mix of
race marriage or something like that he
had a mixed-race kid and i'm like i
don't sound like a white nationalist it
sounds like kind of the opposite but he
was a nationalist and so i reached out
to this journal today to him and i said
hey why did you why did you say this guy
was a white nationalist and he goes
because he is and i was like he's not
he's a nationalist but he's got a mixed
race family and then he goes is he white
and i went yeah and he goes is he a
nationalist and i said yes and he goes
he's a white nationalist
and i was like are you
kidding me yeah you know what that
phrase means
he was trying to imply that it was a
factually true statement because he
meant he was a white-skinned nationalist
person
and not a person person who believes in
a country for white people what white
nationalist actually means and that's
the dirty game they play why if you were
to sue him he would win because he would
say your honor he is a nationalist and
he is white yep and it's not my fault
people interpreted it the wrong way i
was referring to him being a white man
at this park and being a nationalist
that's what it meant and the judge can
then say i don't believe you and then he
can appeal and be like you don't get to
say what my intentions were the phrase
is factually true now a judge might be
like get out of here we know what that
means that's reckless how dare you but
if it but with the um
times v sullivan he could argue this guy
is a prominent public figure who's got a
social media following and what i said
about him was true and it was not
intentional to have it for and then and
they win like the sarah palin thing got
tossed out by a judge
because of the insane standard that we
have today for defamation
that you have to prove they were
knowingly lying or acting recklessly and
recklessly means they were they were um
not upholding their own standards in in
their uh presentation a presentation of
information
so if cnn has no standards you can never
sue them for defamation
no for real and and they clearly don't
have standards i have standards for cnn
does that mean anything no it should be
something
if cnn collectively check
they can say whatever they want say your
honor this isn't this is our normal
process we believed it was true and he's
gonna and the judge can be you can argue
but they didn't do any fact checking and
then i say your honor we don't do fact
checking
we hear rumors we publish them it's what
we do
and the judge might be like well that's
reckless or it might be like you're
entitled to your opinion and to publish
what you think
it feels like kids are are fighting and
i'm like okay they're fighting about
this word in this language when i'm like
we got asteroids bombarding the planet
the power could go out at any minute the
land could flood we we have real
problems and
this is just but it's like watching kids
fight and then i'm reminded the kids are
in control of the military like
everyone's listening to the kids
and the kids get to decide which
direction the nukes point
yep
they can't pick something worse to
compare it to either it's like january 6
january 6 that's the worst thing ever
that's the that's what we're worried
about that's the worst thing ever ever
is january 6 there's so much bad crap
happening like the fire bombing in
philadelphia
yeah yeah the what was that move bombing
yeah yeah yeah there's the bombing of uh
uh the tulsa bombing like yo if you want
to talk about bad things happen in
american history we are we our history
is rife with really awful things yeah
and tim didn't they do a survey of like
the average voter and everyone's like
january 6 what the what is that i am not
familiar with no i think i think they
did there was a bunch of like panels and
polls that found people knew what it was
but didn't care yeah they were like i
don't understand how this impacts my
life right and again you raised such a
good point ian in that and we do have
real problems like there are real like
if you ever wanted to get truly
depressed when you sit down and think of
some of the major problems facing the
country the world like there are some
really big
heavy structural problems
but we're fighting about you know if joe
rogan and and we're still we're playing
these little tiny games and you make we
begin to wonder is it an intentionally
nice because joe rogan makes you think
about the real problems going on in the
world that's why they attack him people
i think don't know the solutions so they
are panicking and now they're just
focusing on what they what they're able
to understand which is this base stuff
this basic crap like
racism and stuff and i think that's what
justin trudeau is doing and when you
panic in that sense and you have power
you exert it the wrong way i think
justin trudeau is in panic mode and he
he's like the little hall monitor right
i think there's a good bipartisan like
sitcom that can be put together if you
just play the jokes right like i'm
imagining you know we're talking about
whether people care about this you've
got like nancy pelosi and she's in like
a um
what are those what are those things
called where they bring in a bunch of
people and ask them about their products
focus group
she's like looking at a focus group and
there's like a bunch of people and she's
like
now now
you know we would like you to vote for
us and it does her pitch and she goes
now january 6 i'm sure you're all very
worried about this and the guy goes i
need insulin and she's like yeah but
january 6 and it's like pens cost a
thousand dollars like there are things
the left and the right are both angry
about yeah and they're just like yeah
and then someone's kid's like i'm hungry
and then she goes shut up shut up
january 6th january
it's actually like that family guy joke
where lois is like 9 11 and then
everyone claps
and then you know they're like but what
about healthcare and she goes nine
11.
i'll start clapping yeah it's funny how
seth macfarlane wrote that joke but now
seth macfarlane is on the side of the
despotic insane people yeah
you either you either die a hero or live
long long enough to see yourself become
the villain right yep thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time